ANNOUNCER: All right.
So please give me a hand in
welcoming to the stage Jenn
Lederer.
[APPLAUSE]
JENN LEDERER: Hi.
I am Jenn Lederer,
and you are a unicorn.
Now, what just went
through your mind
when you heard me say that?
When you heard "I
am a unicorn," were
you closer to the side
of yes, I am a unicorn.
Thank you for finally
recognizing me.
Or were you to the side of
at best, you're skeptical.
Now, for the unicorns in the
room-- those of you who are
like totally embodying,
already knowing-- welcome.
Really excited to have you.
But the others, the
skeptics, the ones
who question what in the
world I could possibly
be getting at with that,
the ones who maybe rolled
their eyes a little bit when
you heard it, even if it was
an internal roll-- you are
the ones that I'm really
excited to be with today.
Because I have learned that
one of the fastest ways to grow
is by learning to ask
the right question,
by having a critical
mind, and by embracing
that skeptic that kind of
likes to talk a lot of game
in the back of your mind.
So don't shy away from the
questions that might come up
today, because
everything I'm here
to share with you
was actually born out
of my own skepticism, my
own questions and doubts
about what is being taught
in regards to leadership.
There's all of these buzzwords
around leadership, right?
Be authentic.
Just own your power.
Be vulnerable.
Lean in, right?
Just own your shadows.
And here's the thing-- I
agree with all if it, OK?
I think it's great.
Authenticity rocks.
But the way I see it being
talked about can a lot of times
lead to misunderstanding,
pressure
to be a certain way--
which when you're thinking
about being authentic
just seems ridiculous--
and it can lead to pain.
So here's an example of a
scenario, a conversation,
that I have seen play
out multiple times.
So someone says, hey, I'm really
ready to step into my power
and own my greatness
and be a leader.
Where do I start?
So all you have to
do is be authentic.
Really, just be yourself.
Um, OK.
I got that.
Really appreciating that.
Thank you so much.
But a quick follow-up
question-- what do you mean?
So like you just
need to be yourself.
Own your vulnerabilities.
Put your shadows into the world.
Really show people that you have
overcome all of your battles,
and you are stronger.
Um, again.
Really appreciating that advice.
One last follow-up question,
though-- if, let's say,
I'm not 100% confident
with what I have to say,
or I'm actually not even sure
I'm worthy of being a leader.
And then I don't even
know what to say.
What then?
So it sounds like you
just need to believe
in yourself a little more.
Like have you tried
positive affirmations?
Because I feel
like once I really
started to believe in myself,
it was all good from there.
Thank you.
Again so much for
that amazing advice.
And then you're left
with OK, I get it.
I get it.
The key to my
success lies within.
I get it.
But there's all this talk
about what you have to do.
Be authentic.
Be vulnerable.
But there's not a lot of talk
about how you are supposed
to get there and
what it is really
supposed to look like for you.
So much pressure on that
vulnerability piece, right?
And I see this trip
people up a lot.
They will say things
like, Jenn, OK.
So I have a story,
but I'm not really
sure I'm ready to share
it with the world.
And is that honestly the
only way I make a difference?
I have been expose my deepest,
darkest secrets to the world
to make a difference?
And then there's people who
say Jenn, I don't have a thing.
I have lived a kind
of blessed life.
I don't have this big terrible
thing that happened to me.
So does that mean
that I'm not as
effective as a leader
as someone who has
been through hell to get here?
And then there's this
really weird message
about trying to be grateful for
the things that have happened,
right?
Trying to love the difficult
challenges in your life.
Now, it may sound like I'm
mocking some of that advice,
because I am, kind of.
But again, all that has a place.
You guys all have a
positive affirmation laying
in front of you right now.
You are limitless.
I believe in the power
of a lot of this,
but only when it's
used correctly,
not from this place of
pressuring yourself to stretch
outside of your comfort zone
farther than you're ready for,
or risk the safety of yourself
in honor of leadership.
So what if it's not about
the thing, the story?
What if it's not about
what you're putting out
into the world, and it's more
about how you are showing up
in the world, being, not doing?
So to help me kind of explain
this journey of coming
to conscious leadership
and how you can get there,
I brought some friends.
I brought some
friends along with me.
And these friends
include a unicorn--
if you didn't see it coming,
this unicorn represents
you and me, but you as well.
So we have a unicorn.
We also have troll
doll-- a little throwback
to some of you, I know.
This guy represents your fear,
your self-sabotage, your ego,
all of the noise that
gets in the way right
before you go and try
and do something great.
That's this guy, OK?
And our stomping
grounds for this journey
are built out of rose quartz.
So this first rose
quartz is intuition.
The second rose quartz-- I feel
like Vanna White at the moment.
Excuse me, let me step
to the other side--
the second rose
quartz is safety,
the third, authenticity,
and the fourth, impact.
Now, if it's not
about the thing,
if it's not about your
story, if it's not
about clinging to a specific
identity of something that
happened or something
you experienced,
or something you
feel that you are,
if it's not about that, then
what are we looking for?
And what we're here to
look for and explore today
is the lesson, the lesson
you learned because
of the thing that happened.
And if you're
someone in here who
has lived a really blessed
life and you're like,
I feel like I
don't have a thing!
Trust me.
You've picked up some
lessons along the way living
in this world.
The lessons that
turn into patterns
that turn into beliefs that
turn into a false truth
that you pick up and embody
and carry with you every day.
Your story is not with us today.
It's in the past.
But your patterns, your
beliefs, the things you feel
are true about yourself,
those are with us right now.
That's where I want to be.
Big believer of the
power of present moment,
so that's where
we're gonna stay.
The things that are
with you right now
are the most powerful tools
to learning about yourself.
So you have to understand--
we're coming in mid-scene here.
We're like turning
on the TV mid-scene,
back in the day when you
actually turned on the TV
and didn't just pick
what you wanted to watch.
And the unicorn just had
a thing happen, right?
Something just happened.
And she's having a
conversation with her fear,
and it sounds something
like this-- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
Something just
happened, and I need
to make sure that that
thing never happens again.
Oh my God.
And fear is sitting
there saying, I know!
I told you not to do that!
I told you not to
be so noticeable.
I told you to stay
under the radar.
What we learned today?
What have we learned today?
And the unicorn
says, well, I learned
it's not safe to be seen,
and I'm not lovable.
Now, these are the
unicorn's false truths
that she picked up.
You may have your own.
You may be starting to kind
of realize what yours are.
Or maybe not-- that's OK.
But throughout this
journey, just see
if you can tune into
what are my truths?
That's a question that I would
love for you to dance with.
So as the unicorn
realizes it is not
safe to be seen as a
unicorn, but I still
have things I want to say.
I still have things
I want to do.
Just because it's not
safe to be seen doesn't me
I have to quit altogether.
So she tells fear first of all,
you stay in the dark, right?
This is what everyone
tells us about fear.
Put it in the dark.
Don't worry about it.
Don't look at it.
Be fearless, right?
So let's see how this
works out for her.
We're going to put him back
in the dark, not heard from,
because she said, I'm
going to be fearless.
I'm going to go out in the
world as a white horse.
Now, white horses are still
incredibly powerful creatures.
They can get a lot
done in the world.
So she didn't lose
all her steam, right?
She just realized, OK.
This is what it is.
This is the card
I've been dealt.
So she moves into her first
rose quartz-- intuition.
And she gets quiet, and she
hears it's not safe to be seen.
You are not lovable.
Now, you have to
understand that from here
on out in her journey,
her entire being,
her entire intention, is
always about keeping her
and her truth safe.
No one is going
to make her budge.
No one is going to
convince her otherwise,
because she has learned,
she has experienced
that this is her truth.
But she still has things to say.
So she presses on, leaving
her intuition behind,
because as far as
she's concerned,
the lesson has been learned.
It's not going to change.
So she'll just keep it as is
and know that that's the truth.
Now, in the land
of safety, this is
where you start to gain
the tools that help
support your truth.
So in this land,
this is where you
might start looking for other
white horses, other people who
are playing under the radar,
not rocking the boat too much.
You start to become
very external
with looking at what
other people are doing,
being incredibly aware
of the competition.
Because listen-- if the
internal conversation is
you're not lovable,
the external goal
is I have to at
least be likable.
I have to at least be likable.
Look at me.
So there's a lot of pressure
to get people on board
with who you are to
validate your truths,
to validate this new
life as a white horse,
because you've
got things to say,
and nothing's going to stop you.
Now, in my world,
in this space, I
was solid with my
white horseness.
No one by this point could
tell me I was a unicorn.
And I just moved to New
York, fresh out of college,
here to be a dancer.
Now, you can imagine that
the cocktail of not being
lovable and it's
not safe to be seen
is a killer cocktail to be
bringing into the entertainment
industry, right?
So I would go to
auditions and hate it.
I mean, hate it.
I would have to take
the rest of the day
off just to bounce back
from the damn experience.
And then I would get
called back and not go.
I would not go to dance class
for like months at a time
but still tell people
I was a dancer.
And I didn't realize it at the
time, but all of those patterns
were me supporting my
truths, keeping myself safe
because I had learned
it's not safe to be seen.
I'm not lovable.
So I'm going to go
almost but not quite.
I'm going to go as far
as it is that I'm safe,
and then I'm going to pull back,
because it's called survival.
Moving a little bit farther,
I accepted that, OK.
The dance is not going
to be where I'm at,
because I don't show up for it.
So I started singing.
I co-wrote an
off-off-Broadway show.
I co-wrote an album.
They did great.
The performances were awesome.
The songs were amazing.
But I did not do one
performance sober.
I was at least three
drinks lubricated
by the time I stepped on stage.
Not because I so badly wanted to
embody the rock star lifestyle
and be drunk on stage.
I really didn't even
realize what I was doing.
And again, looking back, I
was fighting for my truth,
saying I am a white horse.
And it might not
be safe to be seen,
but I'm going to
do as much as I can
in the limits that
are in my life.
So I danced with that
for a while, with almost,
but not quite.
And then as I moved into being
authentic-- now you guys.
You have to realize--
I was being as
authentic as I knew I could be.
By this point, the
fact that I was unicorn
was like a deep
buried memory at best,
if I even had the memory of it.
Now by this point, I had
gotten the opportunity
to run a talent
management company.
Now, this was like,
oh, I found it!
I found my sweet spot!
I can help people get
into the spotlight,
but I can be an arm's length
distance from it and feel safe.
And I was good at this job.
There was negotiating.
There was power.
I was a decision maker.
I was working with really
high-powered producers.
I was moving and grooving.
Things were good.
Did I mention I was good at it?
So I stayed, because why not?
I finally found a
nice balance where
I could work with
artists, I could
be involved in that world, I
could also stay in the shadows,
make an impact, be
authentic, and stay safe,
because I was fighting
for this truth.
You have to understand
that everybody is doing
the best they can at all times.
It may not seem that way.
But everybody is fighting
for their truths.
So as I moved into impact,
the company was doing great.
Actors were booking
really amazing things.
I was getting compliments
from producers
who were watching me how
I ran my company, saying
you're doing a great job, Jenn.
Keep going.
And then just as I felt like
I was hitting my stride,
I was winning all
the races, right--
I was the best white
horse-- just when
I got comfortable with that,
the whispers started coming in.
And they whisper asked me, Jenn.
If it's safe for all of
these actors to be seen,
might it be safe for you too?
Nah.
Psh.
Ignore that, right?
Because why would
I risk everything
I'd built-- all of my
success, all of the people
who were counting on me--
to continue on this path?
Why would I risk that
to follow a whisper?
No.
Not going to happen.
And that is why I so fiercely
believe that you cannot just
convince yourself
into a new reality.
You cannot just start with the
positive affirmations and think
that it's actually going to
change what you believe to be
true.
You cannot go to a single mom
of two kids who's up at one AM
at her kitchen table, crying,
because of an eviction notice.
You can't go to
her and say, just
believe the universe
is abundant.
What?
You think she doesn't
want to believe that?
You think she
doesn't want so badly
to experience this abundance
that everyone is talking about?
She wants to, but she's fighting
for a truth, a truth that
probably sounds something like
every nickel you earn, you've
gotta bleed for it, and you're
not even worthy of much.
If that is your embodied
truth and someone says to you,
the universe is abundant, they
might well be looking at you
and saying, you're a unicorn.
It doesn't resonate
because everything
she has experienced in her life
thus far has proven otherwise.
So if it's not about convincing
yourself, what is it?
What is it that gets you to
switch and say, oh my gosh,
That might be possible for me?
So in my world, the whole maybe
it's safe in the spotlight--
that whisper was
not working on me.
The universe was like,
OK, she's stubborn.
She's not going to
react to this one.
We've got to go at her
from another angle.
The universe is persistent.
So it went after
my other belief,
the you are not lovable.
And at the time, I
was dating someone
who reveal themselves
to be a narcissist.
And it got to a
point where I had
to stop painting
the red flags white.
I had to look at what was
really happening here--
the lying, the cheating,
the manipulation,
the emotional abuse-- and I
had to look at it and say,
is this really all I'm worth?
And the whisper came in and
asked, what if you are lovable?
The questions-- the questions
that get you to wonder what if?
Not the demand to believe that
it is true, the invitation
to ask what if?
That is the place where
you can begin to have
somebody release their truth.
And that is a really
brave thing to do.
Because you don't know
what's waiting for you
on the other side.
In hindsight, you look
back and you're like, oh,
that's why I had to let go,
because that was coming in.
And it's all real beautiful
from the back end,
but when you're
living it and someone
asks you to let go of the
truth that you have been
living for possibly
multiple decades,
it's going to take a lot.
Or it's going to take
one moment, where
all of a sudden you
realize, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
The thing I thought was
true might not be true.
And with that in my
world, when I realized oh,
maybe I am lovable, then the
maybe it's safe to be seen
came with it.
So I headed back
to the beginning
of where I came from, because
I had somebody to talk to.
I knew that was going to happen.
All right.
So she went back
and talked to fear,
because she was like, hey.
Remember how we said it
wasn't safe for me to be seen?
Well, I'm starting to
doubt that and you had
all this crazy stuff to say.
And fear is like, I'm
so glad you came back.
I've been trying to
get your attention.
You were out there
trying to be fearless.
I'm back here trying
to get your attention
because I'm not your enemy.
And he said, by the way-- do
you know that you're a unicorn?
And she's like, what?
This whole time
I'm out there-- you
saw me-- I'm out there trying.
I'm a unicorn?
Your fear is like, yes.
This is what I've been
trying to tell you.
Can I come with
you now this time?
Can we do it again?
And she's like, yeah.
Hello?
I'm a unicorn now?
I did all that as white horse?
Imagine what I can
do as a unicorn.
Now, the fear says,
I'm coming with you.
Let me get my outfit.
Now, yes, I'm going
to put his outfit on.
I promise you it's
worth the wait.
It's totally worth the payoff.
Because look, you guys.
If you were to hire somebody,
a private investigator,
to tell you exactly what's going
on with you, he's your guy.
Really good news for
everyone-- we all have one,
and he works pro bono.
So this is now a team.
We're starting to
build our squad goals.
So off she goes as a unicorn,
back at her intuition.
Same thing-- she gets quiet.
The truth is it is safe to
be seen, and you are lovable.
So just like before,
everything from here
on out is about protecting
her and her truth,
biding to build that truth.
Now, as she moves to safety,
she's learned listen.
You've got to bring
your intuition with you,
because things change.
Things can change along the way.
This isn't the only
catalyst that's
going to happen in her life.
So she brings the
intuition, and, of course,
you got your man who has your
back, ready to let you know
if anything weird is going on.
Now, this safety,
you guys-- this
is a really important place.
This is where the positive
affirmations can start to work,
because they are no longer
debating your truth.
They are supporting what you now
are already open to believing.
This is where maybe you
have to stop hanging out
with some of the white
horses that really used
to fit kind of who you were.
But now that you're
a unicorn, they're
kind of intimidated by the whole
thing, and it just gets weird.
So you lose some
people in this space.
It can be painful.
This is also the
space where you do
want to explore those stories
and those things that happened,
those catalysts in your life.
This is where you get
to own your power,
and you decide what gets
shared with the world, what
gets put out there.
Because baring your soul does
not equal leadership and power.
Owning your stuff
so you can become
a mirror of what is possible,
that is what we're working on.
So I can't tell you what
authentic leadership
looks like for you.
If that means baring your
soul and telling the world
your story, go for it, right?
It's all you.
If Kim Kardashian needs to
strip down every other week
and get on social media to
feel empowered, hey girl.
Do you.
But there is enough
messaging out there
that is telling people you
have to overcome and prove
that you're stronger than and
can take on all the judgment
because you're fearless.
There's enough of that.
I'm here to give voice to the
person who says, you know what?
There's more to me than one
event that happened in my life.
And this is where
you get to start
exploring all of who you are.
And then when you move into
authenticity, remember,
we're bringing
all of your tools.
You're not leaving
these safety tools
that you just built
behind, because you
know you're going to keep
building them as you go, right?
Asking for help.
Working with a coach.
Working with a therapist.
Really allowing yourself to be
supported, not because you're
weak, but because you understand
that when I get this support,
it allows me to be
more of who I am.
So in this game,
by this space, I
started realizing
that number one,
I want to infuse comedy
into everything that I do,
so I'm going to do it.
It's the kind of
authenticity that when
you book one of the coolest
speaking gigs of your career,
and they're like, hey, Jenn.
Are you going to have slides?
And you're like, no.
But I'm going to bring a
stuffed unicorn, a troll doll,
and some rose quartz.
Cool?
Awesome.
That's the kind of
stuff that happens.
You're not looking
around wondering
what other people are
doing, because it's
irrelevant to what you
are working on here
and what you have to offer.
So this final piece, when
she moves into impact
and she has her intuition, her
safety, her real authenticity--
not the one that
someone told her
she's supposed to have in
order to be authentic--
this kind of self-awareness
is conscious leadership.
Because you start
to become a living,
breathing catalyst for people.
You're not running around
trying to save them,
because you know that the
catalyst is just the question.
The catalyst is that moment
that makes someone go maybe what
I thought was true isn't true.
As a leader, if you can get
people to feel safe enough
to release that truth that
they have been clinging to
for dear life out
of survival, if you
can get people to release
that, that is leadership.
The rest of their
journey, they have
to choose to go back
to the beginning
and talk to their fear about
what the hell went down,
and am I unicorn, and when
did you choose to not tell me
I was unicorn?
That is conscious leadership.
Really owning.
When people say own your
power, step into the light.
Be seen.
When I hear people say be
seen, the first thing I ask
is are you seeing yourself?
So if you don't begin with
positive affirmations,
if it's not just a leap to
convince yourself of what
it is, then where do you being?
You begin by looking
for your truths.
What am I fighting
for right now?
What do I believe so
much that it's true
that I will deny everything
else-- someone could
come in here right now
and tell me I'm a unicorn,
and until I feel that I am,
until I feel that maybe I am,
that's all useless.
Getting quiet, having the
courage to wonder what if.
There's so many people
that say to me, Jenn.
I don't even think
it's responsible for me
to dream in that way.
It's just not responsible.
I've got a job to take care off.
I've got family.
I have things.
I've got things.
It's not responsible
to dream, right?
That's a truth people
hold on to a lot.
I have to keep running my race.
I'm a white horse who
wins all the races.
Don't tell me to slow down.
I'm surviving.
And as a conscious leader,
you are the invitation
that it is safe to start that
exploration for yourself.
A good leader does not
judge their success
by how many people they've
been able to convince,
or how many people are
trying to now be like them.
A conscious leader looks
around at their world and says,
I'm here to help all of
you be more of who you are.
Even if right now
you're a white horse,
be the best white
horse you can be.
So when the question
comes, you hear it,
and you're not afraid of it,
and you're willing to follow it.
So it's not about what you're
putting out into the world.
It's about how you show up.
I am Jenn Lederer,
and you are a unicorn.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]